hier ist unser Onlineshop
das sind da Lager hier sind die Büros es
wird gerade alles saniert und neu
gemacht ihr seht schon das sieht bald
aus wie in Waghäusel bei uns und ich
nehme euch jetzt mal mit rein und Egon
Sarah haben wir auch mit dabei den haben
wir nämlich versprochen das war ihnen
das mal zeigen also kommt mit
auf jeden Fall ist das hier unser
Hochregallager
wo quasi alles angeliefert wird wo war
alles verstauen und dann nehme ich euch
gleich noch mit den dp-halle ja bei uns
gerade irgendwie die halbe Belegschaft
im Urlaub die hatten über Weihnachten
natürlich viel zu tun und die die
Weihnachten da waren haben jetzt Urlaub
und die die Weihnachten Urlaub hatten
die sind jetzt da deswegen ist ja auch
so still aber natürlich wird hier
ordentlich gearbeitet und muss sagen das
hat ja alles im Kinderzimmer von Mikael
angefangen und wenn ich jetzt sehe was
daraus entstanden ist ist so schön
das ist schon schon Wahnsinn